in other news and yep there is other
news congress is close to finishing
president biden's top priority that
giant coronavirus relief package
the senate passed the 1.9 trillion with
the t
dollar bill on a party-line vote that
was on saturday the house still has to
vote on it
ed o'keefe is at the white house with
more on the story ed good morning to you
what's the timeline
for the final action here good morning
gail we expect the house will pass the
senate's version of this bill tomorrow
but here at the white house
they're not resting on their laurels no
sense of complacency here
as they prepare for passage of this
absolutely no room for complacency where
the instructions to white house staffers
over the weekend as they prepare to
implement the legislation a reminder
that it includes those long-awaited 1400
stimulus payments for many americans the
president says
eligible americans should be getting
those payments later this month
there's also some provisions you may not
realize including an expansion of the
child tax credit for a year
of up to thirty six hundred dollars per
child and one of the biggest changes to
the affordable care act in years
34 billion dollars goes to expand
obamacare subsidies
meaning more people will be able to buy
health care on the exchanges and others
will have lower insurance premiums
there's also relief for restaurants and
concert venues
that have been struggling during the
pandemic but there's been no republican
support for this legislation as of yet
and that's a rough sign for
bipartisanship in washington if you
can't get it for financial relief during
the pandemic
will the president be able to get it for
his other priorities like infrastructure
spending
combating climate change or immigration
reform tony we'll have to wait and see
it's an open question but this bill
could help a lot of people ed thank you
very much